[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
pardon je cherche un ami qui m'a donné
rendez vous après la présentation dans
le couloir des loges juste devant cette
porte
fathi ben il est assez saint-jacques
petite moustache grand à peu près de ma
taille
enfin dans mon genre il ira la place à
non non non nous sommes de simples
spectateurs
j'ai pas dit ça bonjour merci beaucoup
moi je continue à attendre dehors alors
vous êtes allés du côté du vestiaire
oui j'en viens parce que mon ami qui est
diplomate m'avait chargé de récupérer
nos vêtements mais mal et j'ai perdu le
j'ai perdu le numéro c'est un pétard
bah oui enfin j'espère que je vais
retrouver moment et c'est un rêve qui
l'habite naturellement oui peut-être
pourriez-vous faire à tous sur le
plateau les soirs de premières sincère
de sa fille et chacun il est friand
merci mais je préfère attendre dix
succès c'est plus sûr vous connaissez
mademoiselle losange
oui on july au plus 10 à 3 mois dans les
délices de capoue j'avais été
enthousiasmé par son jeu sa beauté son
chapsal terre je m'excuse je préfère
rester ici je dois vous expulser parce
que mademoiselle doit venir du minutes à
l'eau je dois préparer ses affaires elle
soupapes à le théâtre avec des amis ah
bon c'est u 6 à l'aube puis nous avons
aussi un salon derrière un de ses très
grands je vois oui là vous êtes et le
reposoir on y met rifle
bonsoir nommé dit à propos de fleurs non
mais je m'en vais tout de suite mais
avant je voudrais me permettre une
courte question oui je suis ici tous les
soirs à partir du caire après huit
heures oui alors si vous le voulez bien
m'expliquer la suite demain non m
c'était pauvre à tout à ça et ne sachant
pas je vais fait livrer des roses
est ce que vous avez sur les apporter
voyez vous-même damas et dépêchez-vous
de presse que mademoiselle le sens
j'aime les roses on bat les valeurs les
miennes garde tombe à l'eau
je me disais aussi ça m'aurait étonné
elles paieront vous pensez ça ira très
bien monsieur mars
la france adresse ses 2 rue des petites
écuries
j'ai tout de même dommage que vous
n'ayez pas peut-on envoyer des orchidées
maintenant l1 et folle mais quand on en
reçoit sont toujours à l'honneur voyez
vous même monsieur qui lui est aux
coureurs de manganèse alors oui je sais
que monsieur le sont en jeu non monsieur
sert balle le banquier mademoiselle me
dit toujours que c'est même ce qu'il
sait faire de mieux
d'ailleurs les accusés sont très chers
oh la la c'est dommage c'est dommage que
j'ai pas pensé aux orchidées
comment elles sont rouverts arranger ça
s'il vous plaît si ça peut vous rendre
service je peux moi vous faire une
proposition à bon je vais vous épinglez
sur les orchidées de monsieur auquel tu
as je mettrais monsieur sur les 11 s'il
s'aperçoit qu'ils pourront garder ça
fleurit semonce à le répéter ce serait
pas tant ce alors madame madame madame
madame lagarde si c'est possible et sans
que ce soit irrespectueux surtout mettez
monsieur sur les roses y laissera pas
bien ses supposés on a quand même des
scrupules à à we hope
oui mais naturellement je tenais voyage
en france pour vous je ne regrette rien
pas l'iran menace et à tout à l'heure et
ne me remerciez pas observer cette
minute de folie à son prix à bâle nord
qui dit on n'est pas plus radin qui
s'imaginent que je vais changer les
cartes du poignet
des amis - gars ce n'est pas le voir
bras pleut ça m'a plu les gens que tu
connais bien avant de mourir parce mois
dans l'autre cologne j'aime le fait qu
au nom non alors ça je ne veux pas
personne surtout ce soir jérémy dans mon
portefeuille
si on me le demande je reviens en ligne
mais que vous échangez comme la tante
agathe ce coup là et glacial
n'est ce pas là j'en sais quelque chose
moi et qui m'a compris zagré a tous
besoin de gros lot
excusez moi mais si on ferme les plus
forts adela mais pas seulement
il vise à envoyer des fleurs alors
prenez pas aurait pu quand même lui dire
merci
c'est pas très important avaler plus tôt
se cacher on trouvera mois légèrement la
gorge et très chaud ça tombe bien ouais
[Applaudissements]
mon avenir exige c'est gagné haut la
main de vous avez peut-être me rappeler
c'est fou permettez je nomme je suis là
harry warden et moins de cerval je vais
ignorer si votre situation ici vous
confère certains privilèges mais je
pense que les miens en porte sur les
ventes et je clos l'allusion ceci dit
régine vous avez été bien merci mon ami
mais pour lui ce que viendra à mon âge
monsieur on met de la mesure dans son
langage en votre dent mais guère même
dans ses salles
ceci posé je vous demande ce soir un peu
de discrétion j'aimerais ne pas insister
sur ce point délicat compris c'est
promis nécessaire balle je compte bon
dieu a naturellement monsieur serval les
filles de vous chamailler
les deux eaux c'est très fatigué ma
patience ou prennent on enfin nous
causions mais vous causer un plus haut à
mon gré et sur un ton familier qui ne me
convient pas je laisserais tomber c'est
certain vous le conseille c'est fini oui
mais d'abord qu'est ce que vous faites
là ici ce soir mme chirac
je pensais que nous occupons ensemble
c'est certain nous pas vous j'aurais mal
compris monsieur certains qui vous
invitez c'est moi qui ai pris l instant
va nous accompagner besoin d'allumer
plus que deux mois sans doute autrement
mais n'insistez pas servat le moment
projet très mal donnez moi plutôt votre
avis sur la pièce savais que je me suis
toujours interdit de porter un jugement
tueur et pièces des autres mais je dois
avouer que je vous ai regardé toute la
soirée avec un plaisir constant
entendait aussi j'espère là au moment
d'un trou était si mauvaise que ça
croyez-moi résine pas de pile
moi je suis gonflé à bloc et tout le
monde pareil prime se servent à lusa va
me prendrait la parole quand on vous
fera signe bien monsieur certains comme
été dans les cigarettes dans la boîte où
vous les avez pris je vous avais une
fâcheuse tendance à adopter les cadeaux
qui ne vous sont pas adressés on ne
savait qui sera son premier - monsieur
certains matchs de grainage à peine cinq
mois de l'indélicatesse car enfin bon
dieu
double emploi de secrétaire amateurs et
le chauffeur occasionnel ne vous donne
pas ici tous les privilèges
ben vous ne dites rien régime je
continue à vous écouter c'est déjà beau
c'est vous qui avait exigé que nous
gardions nos services rappelez vous
mettez à ce temps j'étais là avant vous
d'autres que moi aussi et qui ne le
gênait pas davantage mais je n'ai jamais
accepté ce pacte je les subis doit venir
moi que vous preniez bien c'est lui ou
c'est moi il ya des convenances tout de
même pas me reprocher ce que j'ai fait
pour vous mais vous l'avez mal et mon
ami comme la plupart des tandis que lui
lui n'est pas encore un homme s'est déjà
on va n'exagérons rien quand même que
vous avez bien lu la dette dans la ville
ce sont les cravatés moteur il est pas
difficile mais en tendance déjà ça je le
suis davantage c'est ce que vous voulez
dire non les enfants ne nous fâchons pas
maintenant qu'on l'appelle la vie est
belle c'est bon je mange je ne vous
reviendrait pas et dans l'état où vous
êtes c'est en effet ce que vous avez de
venir faire allez vous vous êtes pas
renié le spectacle d'une crise que sont
venus en gallo elle arrive tellement à
l'évidence vous attendez que j'éclate
420 beauté de l'art c'est ça vous voulez
mais parfois il faut combiner ses
services et la pagnol en bas non
monsieur je suis d'ageas me conduire
tout seul un contrôle chez maxi non
monsieur je ne souffrais pas ce soir
plutôt je souffrais sans vous mais
surtout régine pas de découragement pour
une femme de votre valeur tous ces gens
qui vous entourent n'ont pas
d'importance c'est exact mais de grâce à
l'avenir choisissez vos roues
et n'allez pas vous compromettre dans
ces sortes d' aventure il ya encore dans
paris dieu merci des hommes d'esprit et
qui ne demande qu'à vous rendre service
mais vous lirez ceci nous en parlerons
ensemble affectueusement et voici ce que
je propose vous viendrez passer les
fêtes de pâques chez moi dans ma ville
là du touquet tous les deux à l'abri des
indiscrets
nous ferons la mise au point ce sera
très agréable
le casino est ouvert à pâques jeu
l'ignorent et je ne vous salue pas
monsieur boni bénin faure le tout cas
pas sans toi sur mon e
je suis pas encombrant pour résumer mais
proprement tout le serait davantage d'or
monsieur le maire mais pas demain nous
avons besoin de calme lune et notre jeu
en panne d'essence à pourvoir les
garages sont fermés à part je sache non
rien mais ma poste de pablo 50 ans après
c'est pas non j'allume arranger connaît
et qui connaît il vaut mieux couper
comptant alors ici là
je rapporte la manette non ne change
donc pas tes habitudes
enfin bon ça reste dort bien dans la vie
what he poos avance crois moi mes côtés
je suis servie avec ses deux imbéciles
mois qu il nomme de paysanne qui
donnerait toujours du monde pour vivre
dans une ferme isolée par monts et chant
ou quand je pense que la ville compte
plus que je sais qu il me donne un
gardien de ce que j'aime quelle horreur
si même mazet n'a plus besoin de moi
dernier métro pour b comparé à 15 je
suis seul je vais être accompagné galore
dépêchons-nous parce que j'ai hâte
d'être chez moi née graff mois elle
mazel et pourtant aimé nous on veut pas
mais en tous les cas pas bien ce qui
intéresse les hommes c'est mon nom parce
qu'ils en ont peut-être sur les affiches
ne sais pas moi moi ou heures mais ne
connaissent pas la demoiselle épargne à
moi elle n'a comprise c'est tout juste
s'il ne met pas aux enchères cet affreux
les allemands feraient autant à moi que
je ne m'habille jugera à faire ça nous
faisait la vienne a passé en tout temps
été si heureux de faire ma route au bras
d'un compagnon loyal fort auprès d'eux
qu'ils aimeraient vivre en province
alors non aux colonies on vous dit ça ce
soir
non vous au couvent odieux que j'aurai
du couvent un vassal engage à rien mais
ou ml mais qui n est ni une vieille
tante de truc qui me gâter avec des
riens qui me semble aujourd'hui un court
d'un joueur que je ne connaîtrai plus
d'un j'ai une maison là bas tous dit
moelle et irrésistible plaisir on a tu
veux vraiment je vous le promets m
mentionne t de miettes gros mais moi moi
moi mais je ne lâcherai même modèle ses
premiers ac n'a pas d'impact que tu
oublies qu'il fait froid pack qui ne
pensent pas plus elle est gelée à tulle
dans une maison peut bomber alors n'y
avait qu'un été lésés telle était ma
grande tournée d'amérique et d'antivols
agathe d'une passoire du défunt faux
bond à tous mes amis de la boxe qui vous
reçoit comme une reine j'avais cru
comprendre par les couvents sa d'oublier
chicago où j'étais dit que j'hésitais
entre mille solutions à cette fait
normal quand on ne sait pas où on veut
aller c'est qu'on n'est pas si mal où en
est on veut voir personne ce soir
seulement endormi tu viens un peu non
tout compte fait je vais aller danser
dans sa saveur est seul dans la nuit
sera blanche taillée en betty collégiens
ont bordé qui les tours dira de ses
sorbets et c'était peut-être
que sait-on jamais ce que tu veux faire
mais en définitive un second mandat non
non non on se promène on se promène dans
les rues sont dans la nuit jusqu'à
l'aube
à liège à part ces quelques questions
avant bien sûr au quai où as-tu la terre
quelle bonne surprise
bonjour agathe alors toujours fidèle au
poste laval ouvriers alors c'était vous
la vie de monsieur mais oui oui mais
vous connaissez plus d'euros on s'est
connus y avait accord nous étions
devenus qu'ils pouvaient avoir vos
traces avec thegero rien nous tenons
d'assez près maman et moi
merci madame agathe et ses vestiaires
personnes comment il m'a rapporté un
pardessus deux garçonnets avec dans
l'est avec dans les poches les grandes
sommaire la voix heureusement j'aurais
qu elle mais arrêter le tennis à ciel
pour moi sûrement ça à part ces agapes
peut-on voir mademoiselle major je suis
désolé monsieur gaston elle vient de
sortir
[Musique]
pour moi elle est la vie
mauvaise humeur wen à feu vous savez
comme nous autres dans les autres
parties non mais rien de grave j'espère
non mais ce soir elle hésite entre eux
tu le couvent et sa tournée d'amérique
pour un écho va pas très bien non je
crois que ça va se terminer par une
promenade à pied à travers les rues pour
nous dénouer les liens au ça ce serait
une bonne idée parce que on pourrai vous
accompagner avec gaston basse et ce
toute charge la veille
ceci dit on garde prévenait comme même
régime que son vieil ami gaston de
l'avoir avec moi et serait heureux de
lui présenter son ami maçon c'est bien
essayé que je n'ai hier confiant droit
aussi c'est quand même ce serait
tellement dommage
et merci madame agathe pour le petit
service j'ai vu que vous aviez fait le
nécessaire
je n'oublierai jamais tenues voilà
cinquante francs pour vous donc tu
gagnes c'est pas pour elle la merci du
poids il doit d'être à mieux atteindre
mais regarde mais c'est el oro chute ou
un comme ces cieux sont extraordinaires
bon il est foutu en comminges erreur
maintenant mais comprends moi gaston il
y entre cette femme et moi commun comme
un déclic qui s'est produit dans b tu
voudrais masseron donnes tout ce que tu
possèdes tout ce que tu as eu tant de
mal à gagner pendant des années des
années de travail et cette femme sera
toi et bah je je donnerais pas tout
parce qu'il faut quand même se garder
signalés une fois pour la soirée mais je
donnerai et avec regret parce que quand
même ça se trouvera au coin des rues
mais je les donnerai quand j'étais je le
donnerais tu vois où j'en suis mort est
ce que tu crois que j'ai des chances
aucune mais pourquoi
d'abord parce que cette femme n'est pas
libre je sais pas avec qui elle est
présentement même si on n'est pas seul
autant là mais pas quand on aime ça
arrive aussi et l'autre par mon vieux
lucien et là je parle au nom de la
vieille amitié que je te porte et qui
sera bientôt qu'une seule quitte même si
cette femme était ni bruit de prendre un
point devrait se dire et lucien ou le
camp tu brûles et tu vas être réduits en
cendres bien ce que j'ai toujours pensé
tu n'entends rien à l'amour ecoute-moi
du sien dans la vie tu es libre tu perds
je ne suis pas que libraire
je suis aussi un primeur vsh est oui à
châteauroux et alors et alors le
commerce est aussi honorable et aussi
lucratif en province qu'à paris
tu sais j'ai mes propres ateliers mais
ma chaîne m'appartiennent ggd réservé
aux banques et encore plus au dehors
mon petit gaston je vis préside le
syndicat de l'indre et d'initiatives et
je suis très honorablement connus oui à
châteauroux mais alors tu oublies qu'une
femme comme regina le tout paris à cépie
et ben alors à tous châteauroux avec
comment comptes-tu l'éblouir tu n'as pas
la prétention des pâtes et une reine de
paris avec ta 2000 vedette à châteauroux
c'est très beau des libraires marque le
message que je ne suis pas que
commerçants jouent publiant luxe les
plus belles éditions de chasse
d'exploration et de voyages j'ai édité
charcot et peterson tu le sais et je
pourrais te réciter par coeur les plus
grandes expéditions sur la banquise ou
dans la jungle et thiam sans aller plus
loin je connais bornéo que je vient
d'éditer comme si j'avais passé ma vie
entière et j'ai parcouru et cinq parties
du monde s'en aille avant de me les
pieds alors l'allemagne
quelle nouvelle si vous n'êtes pas trop
pressé je crois que mademoiselle va
finir par se décider à paraître bientôt
vous exprimer nous n'avons pas prévu de
passer la nuit ici alors qu'elle se
décide de cinq minutes encore jetons
flynn comprendra que sommes indésirables
mais non monsieur normalement jadis a
simplement répondu quand j'ai dit votre
don c'est à farah clip celui là on le
bat les années bissextiles
ce peut être aujourd'hui bonne augure
papa m'a demandé comment et l'autre j'ai
répondu le plaisant aux méfaits vous me
l'avez prouvé
je n'oublierai jamais ma la bagasse et
moi en tout 25 94 je vous prie à teillé
messieurs alors sachons nous en dit plus
allo maxime joyal berne
agathe la camériste mêmes mannes aux
anges bonjour j'ai ravine l'émission de
mademoiselle nos enfants que ce qu'il
leur table ils sont arrivés
merci c'est tout ce que je voulais
saveurs vous m'excusez si joachim et
wacken et puis fixer cette fois on part
oui au nom gaston juste encore un
instant tu t'en supplie tous français je
suis quand même monté par cet endroit
tous ces objets qui nous entourent
tellement tellement différent tellement
nouveau pot effet comprends moi effleuré
sa main ne serait ce qu'une seconde
fixer son regard enregistré son sourire
et la voir là tout d'un coup à un mètre
de moi et les bugs ou d'un mètre ou deux
c'est pareil tu finiras ta litanie
d'horreurs tu viens or non mais j'aurais
tellement voulu être pour un soir
seulement un héros authentique bombe a
tué dit charpot c'était pas mal console
toi
bon on va sauver tous les deux d'une
offre le champagne demain pouvoir à
l'umih chier tu penseras qu'apple est
maintenant tu es dur gaston - alors ne
vous vexez pas de ce que je vais vous
dire mais je crois que si monsieur
gaston avait été sa demoiselle aurait
dit oui elle a horreur des têtes
nouvelles ça me repose sur rien mais
c'est comme ça bon enfin tout s'arrange
pour le mieux au contraire tu vas
l'avoir seul
et moi je vais continuer à attendre de
chez l'habitude depuis lors je ne fais
que ça voulait d'abord non je vous
remercie c'est inutile mais temps je
demande tenir à rendez-vous pour la
semaine
je rentrerai plus tard à châteauroux et
didier surtout que la nouvelle tête est
celle d'un honnête homme profondément
épris et qui pour elle serait capable de
enfin famous et puis tiens ta rencontre
à cette question je pense bien s'y tient
ça se voit donc pas bon allez entendre
merci dites lui que je suis seul mais
n'oublie pas que tu es là derrière
bonsoir mon cher question je ne vous ai
pas fait compétent mais pas du tout
j'avais battu les ici heureux de voir
pourtant sur ce soir je suis si
malheureux
réveillez-vous deux minutes alors que
devenez vous et vous un gros bras
c'est une pauvre fille willow for cats
est tout de même des bijoux des
fourrures à l'hôtel la vedette ce que
vous avez tous c'est à dire pas grand
chose
avec tous ces faux grand bonheur là j'ai
bien du mal à m'en sur un peu de vrai
bon ça nous parle aussi du sort elle a
beau ne voulait pas changé mais la mort
depuis tous les avantages non merci mais
je suis jeune et vous le voyez pas ce
que tu me lis pas
qu'est ce que vous faites ce soir vous
emmène soupe est impossible manche et en
ratant chez maxim depuis bientôt une
heure par et demain au ou serai demain
tu peut être vous jouez mal à nourrir
social au début de mois j'ai oublié j'ai
un gala après minuit alors je ne peux
pas que c'est demain je voulais vous
présenter mes z'amis assad ou pas je
connais à sa demande
oui je sais bien mais ce cet ami est un
garde fou tout à fait remarquable sa
veste une personnalité vraiment
exceptionnel tout paris se l'arrachent
en ce moment il est reçue partout à bras
ouverts un très grand bonheur riche
célèbre savant enfin vraiment quelqu'un
enfin écouter battant pipe à eau
mais comme moi n'ont pas en plus mais je
tiens à le voir derrière d'un couloir
alors et comme tous les êtres
d'exception une force par les porteuses
mais il est derrière et oui vous le
faites attendre avant gaga agar agar at
home et fait entrer ce monsieur je te
préviens la dépêche toi mais vite
entrée monsieur je vous en prie monsieur
v je suis très honoré et moi et moi bien
davantage madec mais respectueuse à
manger et une joie sans mélange
maintenant que vous avez pardonné ses
croyez en morvan mais je vous en prie
madame mais au fait il faut que je vous
présente ma demoiselle régine le genre
tu fous là plus justement célèbre de
novell acquis du exprimé le désir d'être
présentée au
c'est exact vous êtes la plus belle
talentueuse de nos artistes
ça va prendre vos costumes sont toujours
un nouveau rock lui dire son v12 annuler
la vie alors la diction s'adonne à une
diction quoi le halo cheville on vous
jouer c'est vrai vous jouez au le jeu
auquel talons madame ont vraiment
j'aurais été navré de ne pas avoir
l'occasion de vous le dire avant de
quitter paris oui ben c'est très bien
dans les meilleurs a mérité ce soir
quand je devrai présenter
oui mon ami m'a souvent le célèbre
explorateur et mails de charcot de
peterson dont la grande modestie cache
la plus firent audace et pour qui notre
petite terre n'a pas de secret deux
passages à paris après une expédition
vol elle est en passe de s'embarquer de
s'embarquer pour les mers australes mas
blanc a tenu à venir vous applaudir et à
vous dire qu'il a connus ce soir une
émotion que la jongle elle même ne lui
avait jamais dit
quand vous priez de me laisser m'asseoir
mais comme tous les êtres de sa trempe
masoe d'un grand timide oui je suis sûr
qu'il m'en veux de le présenter à vous
sous son vrai jour
mais j'ai pensé que l'hommage ne serait
pas clair mais très agréable
j'ai pour les savoirs et les chercheurs
lapébie la demie affirmant aussi beau à
notre époque de penser que de fraises
avons gardé le goût des découvertes et
des grands espaces
je trouve ça et emballant or c'est
affaire de nature mais c'est vrai mais
si j'avais su qu'ils vous étiez je me
serais bien gardé de vous faire attendre
on pensait bien merci pour moi bon nous
sommes de vieux coffre à nous autres
nous n'avons pas à nous donner
mais oui ça vous voyant et sachant
qu'ils vous êtes il me semble en effet
avoir vu votre portrait dans quelques
magazines alors en première page de tous
les journaux au moment de l'exposition
alors si vous avez de voyage hier soir
un gars d'orsay oui ça après bien pis il
taperait chaque voyage et pour sa
famille qui habitent la province
maman est un temps fort j'adore maman
c'est exact une façon naïve et bien ça y
est adorable
on peut dire qu'amazon va partir une
très vieille famille nous ne savons pas
quand mais la maison était fondée en
1862 non non je vous dire que parent
peut elle pas s'y est pas si vieille que
ça enfin on date pas d'hier quand même
ne sommes pas important mais non non non
non non non pas du tout au nom de votre
présence me réconforte au contraire
comme monsieur si vous saviez comme
votre personnalité je suis vraiment je
me sens sauter est tout petit mais
madame c'est à ce point là vraiment oui
ignorante et est même ridicule on ne dit
pas ça valable qui croit avoir tout vu
tu connais pas grand chose mais nous
devons envoyer faire figure de ma vie
chacun son job je pense que nous sommes
quand même accepté mais plus
qu'acceptable madame surtout voudrait
bien attendez merci pour moi seule
journée
bon ça il faut aller loin en france et
même au delà pour découvrir un talent
une beauté comparable aux deux autres
madame x en toute bonne foi oui vous
êtes sincère c'est le trait maintenant
je suppose l'auteur vous avez vu des
caps aux antilles l'équateur aux poules
les femmes sont belles et mystérieuse
jamais je vous le jure plus le choix il
ya trois mois ou variétés où j'ai vu
pour la première fois pas un jour ne
s'est écoulée sans que ce souvenir
inoubliable se soit imposée à moi et
avait comme mais voyons tu n'étais pas
shanghai il ya trois mois à shanghai
puis c'est un rat ne renoncera ribéry
c'était là c'était le noël dernier
non alors qu'angers quand j'ai su que
vous débutiez ici ce soir ça pour rien
au monde il n'aurait voulu manquer ça
oui il a même repoussé son départ pour
bornéo jusqu'au bout
il vient tout simplement du sanskrit et
qu'elle puis magnifique je suis prêt oui
monsieur
racontez-moi bornéo
bordé oh sees bornéo
c'est la plus grande île du monde
sa superficie dépasse celle de la france
est égale à 2 95 de l'angleterre de
l'irlande et de l'écossé municipal et
les pittoresques pas de végétation
géantes comme un célèbre ou à java mais
en revanche beaucoup de schiste
énormément de schiste
et de granit cristal voilà cette fois
c'est tout pour le sol sinon qu'il est
vierge peu à peu près mais vous vous
n'êtes plus là bas c'est je suis plus
moi-même comment vous dire oui je me
suis plus que sans plus la cause des
femmes sont dit oui à vous parlez nous
des femmes de bornéo mortsel sont
charmantes aucun balancement des enclos
de grâce de noblesse si les avis commun
comment elle sa vie
bah vous savez par le cou les poignets
et chevilles tout le reste est à
découvert les chats aussi les uns
auraient pu dit que la moitié seulement
quand même la moitié fin octobre
et elles sont belles ces femmes bas
cette affaire de couleur vous savez ça
tous les goûts sont dans la nature mais
l'ensemble est correct je vous remercie
beaucoup mais tout ce que vous me
racontez là monsieur mazon me passionne
1° que vous ne pouvez pas savoir c'est
mieux à dire enfin je sais pas où ça met
à la rue les êtres obligés de vous
quitter parce que on attend chez maxim
alors depuis bientôt une école domicile
le regret pour moi mais mais nous nous
reverrons je vous le promets l'école
madame dans une huitaine non mais je
peux y compter oui je crois bien que je
sois très changeant entre mai
si vous me promettez beaucoup de belles
histoires je serai et terriblement
tenter bon ben ça alors des histoires
aux tambours dans les matches à fond
avec des détails terriblement bien non
mais moi comme ça au hasard entre nous
excusez-moi agar agar d'abord de moi mon
manteau alesi monsieur prix j'avais
faire balancer chez maxim's je suis venu
vous prévenir si vous êtes prêtre guy
wallemme et une seconde je suis occupée
voilà compte et nous votre histoire
monsieur mal au bras un peu de chose à
vrai dire sinon qu'il existe encore des
tribus ou les jeunes gens peuvent pas se
marier tant qu'ils n'ont pas apporté à
leur future épouse la tête de leurs
ennemis coupet scalpel est réduite à
tout petits volumes grâce à un procédé
spécial dont celle dont j'ai le détail à
la maison de si ça vous intéresse
en tout cas non je n'ai pas vous montrer
des collections sûrement alors que pour
eux la base d'un simple jeu vous savez
écrire à ce que c'est que les distances
quand même fait je ne connais
connaissons
monsieur travaille sans doute en
exportation bon monsieur est un savant
qui a fait le tour du monde en avion à
l'occasion seulement à ce propos il
revient banalement mémoire une anecdote
à la suite da de mes atterrissages
forcés dans la jungle mais ne se sera
pas un jour parce que le temps que je
rassemble mes souvenirs je sais que j'en
ai tellement j'avais atteint nous attend
agathe ne sert pas le cas bien piètre ou
cinq minutes de plus à vous êtes là je
dispose a conduit régime chez maxis le
serbe à l'examen matin les régimes je
reçois mes amis ne me bousculer pas
voilà continuez votre atterrissage au
rien d'extraordinaire madame ne
réminiscence d'une peuplade noir ou
quand la femme accouche c'est le mari
qui se met au lit pendant trois jours et
qui est qui reçoit les compliments de
ses amis de ses voisins de sa famille
dans cette opposition tous en cercle
autour de la natte sur laquelle repose
marie le front ceint d'une couronne de
bongo et chacun y va de son petit fils
et où elle remplace le mari aux travaux
des champs
y'a mieux heureusement
excusez-moi si j'interviens non je suis
tout prêt à vous féliciter de vos
prouesses qui offre certainement le plus
grand intérêt et j'admire
personnellement les héros dans tous les
domaines mais j'attends que nous
partions avec quelqu un patient et sa
compagne m'excuse je suis très bavard
ceci est tellement intéressant qu'on
n'arrive pas se détacher mais j'en suis
sûr et navré d'y mettre fin mais
vraiment monsieur je suis déjà allée est
revenue de chez maxim j'aimerais bien
repartir une bonne foi fait en bas vous
pouvez pas défini mois
battue n'a pas raconté le plus bel
exploit lequel en europe au long le
chien voyons mais ce que je vois pas du
tout ce que veut dire gaston beau et
bien voilà figurez vous m'en a découvert
dans l'hémisphère sud une terre inconnue
à laquelle il a donné un nom de femme là
la roja en souvenir d'une maîtresse et
mais ce n'est pas possible
si ces bas vous savez c'est si peu de
chose mais vous l'avez baptisé d'un
homme vous chéri sierra sur le moment
j'ai pensé que ça fera plaisir à la
personne en attendant le moteur tourne
au bain en images à des marathons
mon secrétaire et mon chauffeur monsieur
serval je vous présente c'est marrant
j'ai oublié de vous présenter mon mandat
bonsoir monsieur je vous salue et encore
tous mes compliments
régine je vous attends pas nous vous
suivons ensemble s'ils restent en jeu
par des dons les fleuves jusqu'à la
batterie venez vous connaissez pas du
tout mais c'est serval vont me tiendrais
au courant je peux compter sur vous ces
jurés me servent à trop peu roi de vous
être agréable à vous c'est certain que
ça
je crois que vous avez fait une grande
impression sur ces messieurs je suis
folle de joie au malawi j'ai dit les
choses comme elles sont c'est tout aussi
mazerat oui j'allais oublier de vous
remercier pour votre envoi de fleurs
il m'a beaucoup lui sied il émeut que
sur ce mode est aux entités ont pas
d'esclandre espèces que nous trouverons
dans les forêts vierges du brésil et de
la nouvelle guinée commencé c'est vous
qui m'avez envoyé ses orchidées à gap
avec tu m'avais dit serbanne j'ai dû
mélanger les cas je vous remercie chers
amis je les adore rien au monde ne
pouvait me faire plus de plaisir lorsque
ravinala mais je sais gré au hasard pour
avoir secouru
oui votre paquet à tombouctou madame
nous prendre un taxi vous pouvez signer
une direction à mascouche au vésinet ne
peux pas dormir à paris avant cela je
supporte mal l'air et le bruit dans les
villes de farce et mal est fait comme
vous l'êtes grands espoirs bon alors ça
y est cette fois aux démarches se
servent à les traîner revanche à moi
c'est juste au coût de la pâte il avait
donné surfeurs portés sa voiture allait
oui surtout régine couvrez vous bien
dans mes frais que ce soit bon alors je
change de montoya et matin matin
n'oubliez pas votre problème chez moi un
soir prochain
ces familles je viendrai le premier soir
on frôla et vous nous raconterait
l'histoire nationale
autant vous en voudrez agathe j'en ai
plein et les valeurs à plein la tête
j'allais jallet café ces montants
belle-maman valent pas et je suis si
bien parti est pas arrivé le tout dit m
tu vois
mais c'est à dire une chose il me semble
qu'une 100 je peux me tromper mais il me
semble que si tout ça devait se
prolonger
je finirai par croire tout ce que je
raconte est vraiment arrivé au madame
pas une reine au monde ne votera l'une
et l'autre grâce à mais d'abord nous
mêmes à bornéo madame alors on y va
riche inouïe limites comme je vous donne
quoi ce qui est pas mon ami et j'arrive
enfin voilà une heure que restant je
vous attends avec la voiture vous vous
rendez compte
mais une heure qui a passé très vite je
dois aller je vous remercie même je
n'oublierai jamais j'adore les histoires
brems et masbou et il a bien raison ce
sont souvent les meilleures ce n'est pas
100 francs pour moudre à la bagarre il
se décèle genre à quelques secondes
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
avec un couteau sacré avec lesquels les
chefs du plateau da rocha et gagnent
pour indifféremment les efi de riz et
les têtes de leurs ennemis ce n'est
qu'elle faillit nous ferons payer 1 pour
les nuls à bord
tour sera jamais prêt alors mademoiselle
oui je voudrais qu'on 13,26 s'il vous
plaît qu'est ce que je vais vous vous me
rappelez bon très bien merci beaucoup
mademoiselle est ce que ces deux horreur
livrade le bon kayhan et céline ni sa
bien-aimée où elle est mieux pour elle a
du courage aux rétais alors oui allô à
auteuil 13 26 oui oui je pourrais je
parlais à mademoiselle de sens s'il vous
plaît de la part de monsieur masseron ça
sèmerait magatte lô balla magath comment
ça va je vous remercie de mademoiselle
losange allait parti pour le désigner à
un très bel astre accident dans cinq
minutes
on attend mieux aura coûté j'étais d'une
passion je pouvais plus il fallait il
fallait comment ben je pense bien que
c'est beau l'amour
et oui oui bah moi aussi j'espère que ça
collera tous les deux comme vous le
dites si élégamment carbonneau a coûté
soyez polis à bondy ça au théâtre pour
porter bonheur
ah je ne savais pas ça et bien je vous
remercie enfin pour l'attention du caa
non à java je passe mon petit âge a
vendu pas ça on dit gong gong
mon dieu c'était pendant voilà voilà
j'arrive
voilà entre est mon ami
écoutez vous est épatant oh c'est le
magasin que nous envoie de la part de
mon ami gaston gestantes margelles si
l'huissier
oh oh oh je savais pas que son rayon
exotiques s'étendait aux gens de maison
mais c'est bien c'est bien c'est bien ça
vous êtes en bonne santé oui c'est le
ciel très bien vous êtes pas dit si vous
êtes né dans quel pays chez les
messieurs est ce que vous savez dire
autre chose que s'ils me siège le mr et
par branche avec ça on vous vous appelez
samedi semble à venir
je lis que vous avez une nature brutal
ces messieurs un peu sauvage et que vos
colères de plus en plus espacées sont
néanmoins redoutable sur l'essieu en
sommes aux certificats sont
encourageants violent mais sobre capable
de tout en bien comme en mal
susceptible mais honnête ah bah c'est
bien ça est ce que vous savez servir à
table
si le ciel est bas c'est parfait je vois
aussi que vous êtes un grand spécialiste
de la brousse et que vous avez convoyer
un lot de six panthère noire depuis
l'équateur jusqu'au zoo de vincennes ou
ailleurs la bonne heure ne vous l'avez
peur de rien vois ça c'est bien
qu'est-ce qu'il ménage
[Musique]
le trouble est pas comme ça
c'est un simple ou dans les radiateurs
voyez il n'y a pas de danger
vaut mieux pas se fier aux apparences 1
je vois que vous appartenez une tribu de
redoutables mangeur d'homme c'est vrai
ça ces messieurs on voudrait travailler
et c'est pas possible ça ça ici c'est
une habitude qui va falloir perdre ici
c'est pas possible
moi je vous préviens mais qu'est ce
qu'il est c'est bien ça nos médecins
c'est la grille écoutez si vous tremblez
comme ça au moindre bruit
on pourra bientôt plus éternue ici mon
dieu mais il vient juste d'arriver
il plaît oui marché plus encore comment
il est mort debout une route peuvent
ouvriers mais les noirs qu'est-ce qu'il
est noir blanc et noirs enfin il est à
attendre
toi qui blanchissent non construit par
jeter plus envoyer ce qu'avait tenus en
magasin oui c'est un kikoo met la barre
haute en titre expert dans le service de
table mais est réputé dans la forêt pour
son esprit absolu de la mort des autres
à redon ille la mort d homme m'a
naturellement je veux prévenir que mal
habitués aux bruits européen
la sonnerie du téléphone en particulier
le faire entrer dans des transes terry
trêve assez punchy
espérons que personne n'appelle haha tu
ne le quitte pas de l'oeil et si tu veux
qu'ils obéissent commande le durement
montagne doit
sanguine vata billets vont faire un
fromage
le cuisinier chinois te dira ce que tu
as à faire
d'abord je me demande si t'as pas trop
bien fait les choses
tu m'as dit de te faire au risque avait
plus couleur locale j'ai pensé qu'un
guerrier chasseurs de têtes valent à
faire qu'est-ce que tu risque pas de me
faire estourbir un poids plus auquel cas
il ya une assurance obligatoire que j'ai
dû contracter les héritiers touchant six
cent mille francs survient alors avait
aucune raison pour qu'elle joue non mais
c'est possible
elle va il paraît aux basses et aigus ah
j'oubliais le jeune lionceau est arrivée
qui s'appelle baromètre baromètre la
drôle de nom pour un lionceau sa non
parce qu'il a dit que le temps il joue
et gambades quand il doit faire beau et
quand la pluie menace les logis sans
arrêt j'espère qu'il pleuvra pas je vais
me mettre de près de la grille dans la
niche frais d'apee pas de la grippe tue
fabec mois de l'année il ya toujours un
mois je suppose qu'on a mais quelle
gueule il à rome 8 mois il ya d'être
sevrés plus de 3000 c'est pas c'est pas
trop bruyant ça par temps sec peuple un
peu la nuit va se rattraper la rage
j'aurais préfère quitter les faons s'est
voulu rassurant il y en a plus de
disponibles en rayon avant alors j'avais
le choix entre lionceaux et un
dromadaire à 5000 alors là j'ai pensé
que ce serait un peu encombrant ah ouais
avec la bosse à prades persie pôle
emploi matin c'est pas tout j'ai pu
avoir pour 2005 un singe laineux du boom
bolt
il s'appelle edward un bon il est là
rires dans la salle de bain je dois
donner un nombre non non non je crois
sur parole vivaient les gens aimaient
que c'est pas fini
commencez pas fini puisqu'il est en
pleine croissance avant il y en a pour
combien dans toute cette ménagerie
atteint 9008 fola harmattan ça comprend
aussi les six mètres de serpents boas à
deux francs 50 le m
eloi de guinée alors très pacifique cela
va tomber à 8 cents alors j'ai payé de
nous fâcher a dit non ça coûte cher les
voyages contre embauche patcher soir qui
t'arrive rien de fâcheux avoue que tu
t'en tires avant qu'on ait tout ce petit
monde est en place
oui je vais mettre les belles d'un
jardin ou hasard un peu partout enfin en
tenons compte des affinités de chaque
fois que me dira où elles sont encore
vous aura besoin de sortir pour que
tacler nom n'a jamais autant faire
marcher dessus tu vois tiens voilà ton
chaque merci bien il me reste plus qu'à
te souhaiter bonne chose que nous les
atouts nombre d'acheteurs merci gaston
et si tu veux un conseil ne ment jamais
à une femme parce qu'à partir du moment
où tu es obligé d'honorer tous mensonges
et de jouer les matamores que tu
n'aurais même pas de quoi je te fais un
lapin crois moi savons de boulot ça
n'arrive qu'une fois dans la vie
malheureusement c'est ça peut arriver
deux fois j'aurai plus qu'à déposer mon
bilan voir entrer à l'asile qu'est ce
que c'est que ça a blessé ma remettre
ces baromètres
et de gaston ce attendu aurait pas de
rester ici pas de moi pour passer la
nuit sur mon vieux
je pars demain pour calmer je tiens à
passer une bonne nuit d'ailleurs tueur
amusé à faire tout à l'heure qu'à
tailler une bavette avec moi oui c'est
vrai d'ailleurs encore je pense au
bonheur qui m'attend une journée les
larmes aux yeux
c'est pas le moment de pleurer non mais
tu as vu un j'ai pas lésiné pour réussir
mais c'est fou ce que je fais là - tu
dors bien la nuit très mal je ne pense
qu'à régine et je n'ai jamais su faire
deux choses à la fois à l'oreille c'est
un goûter
parce qu'il a chanté comme ça puis là
c'est peut-être parce que c'est bourré
bien que oui mais voilà il faudrait déjà
que sa méchante quand il fait bon
s'arrêter ici un rêve
pourquoi jeux de mains jeux de vilains
restituait der commence mon travail
si tu parles tu cherches on n'arrivera
jamais à faire obéir avant quand il
n'obéit pas te le dis simplement malouf
pas il comprend tout de suite
ben marofo
stamm à hello mes compliments il
conserve un costume bien fait les choses
à sa pas été facile attendant doute beau
armes table avec tous liés à 3,7 pouces
de bambou préventivement rempli de sucre
de palme était destinée à attirer les
esprits bienfaisant tu le savais ça
m'épuise pâtit réserve et fatiguent pas
pour moi je dis c'est surtout bon à
franchir la mémoire parce que depuis une
semaine je pense mon pas confectionné
des fiches sur tous les animaux et
toutes les coutumes du monde
je m'entends dire que c'est un drôle de
travail jeudi dans le monde et domitien
une question brûle très épris je vois à
moi affolement c'était déjà arrivé mais
jamais personne dans ta vie à mon père
ce afin personne d'important mais
pourquoi toutes ces questions ben parce
que ce qui est arrivé très grave nous on
vient premier amour à ton âge c'est bien
là prévu mais les jeux c'est bien et je
m'en félicite
on a vite fait commettre des bêtises
mais il lui faut que tu es seul pivot de
la vie
on dit ça avant mais on verra après
cette entrée déjà si oui c'était son but
va ouvrir la grille sambi va ouvrir la
farce est vrai qui comprend comment
qu'il m'a dit m'a lufa c'est quoi ça
marche encore à bien en puissance
qu'elle est née au fond du parc la
duchère premiers mois que quand tu auras
gagné la partie tu repartiras tour
château mais ça je te le promet
d'ailleurs j'ai donné ma parole à la
joie mon chef comptable ne t'inquiète
pas je serai de retour dans huit jours
il s'agit pas compromettre une situation
bien assise au et depuis des générations
ça tu as raison régine est une femme
avertie tu t'en doutes vol que j'ai un
droit qu'on a là qu'est ce que je vais
avoir comme plaisir
ce que je dis 1 n'a aucune importance à
mon style couture s'est dit mon dieu la
voilà la voilà c'est pas possible mais
si c'est elle
pour madame au matin bonjour chers amis
environnement
je vous vois j'ai prétexté que j'étais
malade
ah bon oui parce qu'ils aimeraient
d'ailleurs quand je suis très nerveuse
mais ce soir on fera relâche
ah bon c'est noir et très noir et très
impressionnant oui oh bah c'est tout
bonnement c'est un kikoo madame c'est un
kikoo c'est un fait acquis combat là bas
que j'ai racheté que j'ai racheté une
tribu d'anthropophages contre quelques
paquets de caporal et depuis je me suis
dans toutes mes expéditions avec une
fidélité de canis rien que de très
naturel mari femme j'ai mes amis restent
en jeu s'ennuyer j'ai pris ça sur moi je
ne pense pas que cela veut dire non à
tout ce qu'il faut à l'office riz et
cela vous gêne qu'il reste avec nous
pendant la moto go les invités sont les
maîtres donc vous êtes ici chez vous en
propose que ce chez vous soit un peu
chez moi on va d'autant que moi vous
savez monsieur le plus petit coin me
suffit oui
ne vendez pas votre fort par assange à
l'intérêt particulier dans c'est surtout
par charité que j'agis il est seul dans
la vie il ne sait pas conduire à lui
manque sans doute de montreux voyageurs
vous savez monsieur - paris les bars le
tueur et les lévriers ne faut pas plus
pour être vous visez vous reste un je
vous répondrai quand on vous
questionnera non mais je voulais dire
par là que je ne sens pas un seul
instant à comparer à melun mouthe pluie
je vous renvoie la maison noire oui
c'est sûrement bon c'est très simple
comme vous le voyez m'enfin bon des fois
un pied-à-terre juste assez rarement et
dans lequel je ne considère que les
caisses mineurs et mes collections cette
année c'est très curieux cet ivoire
ciselé oui attendait chez audi s4 est
recensée
alors ça ce sont deux fiancés cagan
madame du district de saint rome barre
comme vous le voyez la femme
et puis les sources et du mal oui avec
ces curieux tandis qu'il lui colle trois
pastilles sur le front oui c'est ainsi
là bas que les amoureux échangent leurs
premiers serment cette cage elle est
amusante
celle là je vous dise que c'est le vient
de l'île de bali madame ça n'est
d'ailleurs pas une cage pour oiseaux
mais pour grillon de combat oui d'abord
la remplacer les combats toro parfois de
grillons et et lorsque l'un des
champions meurt de ses blessures
la population lui fallait finir à une
nationale vous avez vu ça de dieu j'ai
eu ça de mes yeux voyez lecteurs déjà
mais parlons plutôt de fou mais non vous
savez j'ai beaucoup hésité
oui mais vous êtes là c'est l'essentiel
je suis très méfiant par nature pour
maman dit tant de fois il est une telle
horreur dimensions ce que je suis devenu
prudent
par contre très prudent je suis très
proche
oui enfin je m'en rends compte et c'est
très bien maintenant
autant je peux donner mon amitié aux
êtres et les plus habiles et puis si je
sais ils sont mais on t'envoie révolte
et à la pensée qu'on aurait pu vous
mystifié par des moyens déloyaux
mais monsieur que l'on monte dans la vie
par nécessité par pitié par amour ou et
mais pour moi on manque loyalement
exactement c'est ça c'est parfait ça
commence bien
voulez-vous goûter oui c'est excellent
oui très fort mais c'est un breuvage
très apprécié des populations de victor
gagnante sartenais montpetit la balle
est notable le boivent à l'heure de
l'apéritif à l'ombre des va au bar si
mes souvenirs sont exacts c'est un
savant mélange d'huile de lin et de sang
de parra
ce qui lui donne d'ailleurs cette belle
couleur rouge à travailler mais si vous
préférez un peu de partout il ya ben non
vraiment franchement très bien une
cigarette au bec sans grands mères elles
sont enroulés dans des feuilles de
bananier c'est la raison préférez-vous
une offre du la non nous nous engageons
je tiens tout connaître contraire on va
lorsque art j'espère j'espère que le
menu que je vous ai préparé ne vous
déplaira pas qu'est ce qu'il avait déjà
fugué doigt sur la toile
je me suis fille qu'elle doit ce ne sera
rien gros morceau de phrase bien
malheureuse karkwa est rempli de flèches
empoisonnées dans la piqûre peut tuer un
homme en quelques secondes
non vous ai pas demandé avant de toucher
casse formel le dehors qu'elle a pris
les mains l'autre bambou ne vous
inquiétez pas je sais prix a tendance à
la gangrène est même arrivé ah oui ça ça
peut arriver
allez venez je n'ai et prenez tout votre
temps ah ben oui on se mettre à table
quand vous reviendrez
j'espère que je serai debout en bas ça
va être fixé très vite voilà tout à
l'heure les idées qu on vienne vers
l'hexagone à m'éloigner hors jeu mais
tellement un peu tout seul avec vous
mais c'est le plus beau moment devant
l'existence mais c'est moi laissez moi
vous regardez madame car vous ne
connaissez pas mon secret oh la la c'est
une histoire extraordinaire bien
différente de celle que vous imaginez
écoutez moi je ne parlais pas avec cette
fièvre mais voilà déjà cette atmosphère
d'intimité je suis très émotive des
travaux pour nous remettre n'ont cessé
ces objets sonores
cette façon étrange je vous ai parlé
avec sang-froid désarmant des choses les
plus inattendus oui c'est parfum grisant
et est hostile à la fois dans tout ici
est imprégné tout cela me disloque un
trouble où vous vous petit soyons ça
c'est autant de malheurs nous serons
tant pis qu'est-ce que vous l'êtes
empire est d'abord passant enfin elle
tel fait mon ami et bien voilà qui suis
je
et depuis quand on connaît avec le bien
vous m'avez vu pour la première fois aux
variétés ya trois mois
venus applaudir l'autre soir c'est ce
que vous m'avez racontez vous avez cru à
ou pourquoi ce n'est pas honorable je
connais depuis six mois j'étais au
canada oui oui et vous l'avez dit non au
rêve à la nana et vous connaissez
gambert oui et pendant un mois je ne
voulais pas quitter des yeux ni des
malades gravement voilà mais j'ai voulu
survivre à cause de vous g en délire je
vous appelez une école je sais ça en a
l'air
on va dire le coup de foudre s'est
produit au cours d'une de mes
expéditions à bornéo madame dans la
montagne terrassés par la fièvre dans
une case des hauts plateaux
j'avais pour toute distraction que la
lecture des quelques revues que j'avais
emporté de paris et un soir sur la
couverture de l'une d'elles je vis votre
image et elle me conquis d'emblée marc
hamel était pour moi la vie l'amour la
femme la france est à 40 de fièvre
je lui faisais des déclarations
provisoire que je n'aurais jamais osé
lui adresser des voix n'exagérez pas si
pour moi vous avez écrit tout cela oui
madame pour votre image
mais quand on aime on est capable de
tout bann à ce son des cornes de quoi
chéramy deux boeufs le cher ami tu es
pour vous à 50 mètres chers amis et vous
la met à deux coups de coups parce qu'il
faut dire que le cerveau d'un peuple
n'est guère plus gros que le point d'un
homme passait un coup très difficile à
réussir
on aurait aimé c'est beaucoup dire on
trippe ben c'est pas sur le moment on
sent pas continuer qu'après qu'on
réalise danger mais tenez pour vous
donner un exemple moi je suis beaucoup
moins aimé devant un lion que devant
vous de ce soir
[Musique]
jusque 6
ça c'est la pluie nous mais c'est régis
semences et la pluie était annoncée
passer sa part belle c'est par où
passait le jeune lionceau que auquel je
m'intéresse et quand le mauvais temps
menace il est très agitée rien comme on
va vous avez des lions c'est un sommet
dame un seul je suis dit les autres au
zoo de vincennes et il est attaché
solidement j'espère il l'était j'ai ce
petit dernier casseroles à l'arrivée il
est là tout près à prête à bondir
mais il a huit mois c'est inoffensif à
cet âge là c'est sans danger n'en croyez
moi si je voulais je pourrais le faire
taire ne vous excusez pas madame même un
homme aguerri n'est jamais bien crâne de
vente un lion les villas vous voulez que
je récuse
[Musique]
il est renvoyé mais vous n'en convient
parc ela la fortune ni comme s'il ne
connaît pas call me madam vastes écarts
mais faites comme moi ça n'est
qu'affaire le moment est ce que cette
mauvaise que c'est là qu'est ce que ça
veut dire un instant j'aperçus baromètre
près de la grille il a commis
l'imprudence de détail et à toutes
jambes en cas d'erreur c'est simplement
ce qu'il fallait pour faire alors là
dessus de lyon s'est fâché mais elle a
bien fait si régulier il a fait une
série de bons enregistré peur j'ai cru
qu'il allait briser sa chaîne
non je n'ai que ça il a favorisé suspens
et pas y voir oui je te remercie pour le
moment on va passer à table je voulais
bien essayé d'oublier ce léger incident
relais place je vous en prie c'est pas
très fan ça fait rire regarder manger
voilà le riz commençons par le riz car
le riz est la base de toute nourriture
orientale sans riz par des civilisations
possibles notamment le préparez vous on
ya à peu près une trentaine de noeuds
roses différents envoyés de sumatra
bornéo
alors j'ai choisi de vous faire goûter
l'horizon nativa très apprécié eu égard
aux hormones qu'il contient mais c'est
harry de père de famille c'est bon et
très vichy
visez ça vous arrache la gueule mais
grâce temps vous vous croyez vous
n'oubliez pas là-bas jeune homme que
l'homme récolte le riz à la sueur de son
front
car à bornéo comme ailleurs les cas il
ne tombe pas tout rôti dans la bouche
des gens et je radical
alors on coupe en hollande
oui ça ça devait arriver
ça me gêne pas qu'ils postent aprilia
pendant qu'on mange un rythme sans doute
oui oui oui il a pour but de conjurer
les faits des poisons qui risquerait de
s'être glissée dans un aliment même ne
renie rien j'ai tout choisi bon m
alors ne vous inquiétez pas 1%
d'assiette comment on chante assise à ne
pas du tout là bas on fait des mélanges
mais puisque c'est alors ça madame ce
sont deux chinois le vieux de 60 ans ils
ont été conservés est scellée dans des
briques avoue brisé les scellés ou comme
ça et leur apparaît dans sa petite halle
berry dont j'ignorais que pareil au bon
vin les oeufs se bonifiant oui moi aussi
avant d'aller là bas vous aimez oh c'est
une pure merveille
mais ce passage mais moi je préfère
écouter des petites languettes trouve
l'accord vague de la sauce verte mais
régalez-vous jeune homme je vous en prie
aussi baissé merci beaucoup
j'allais oublier vous servir à voir sa
gauthier chou de palme et alcool de
certains termes d'amour après avoir bu
pourra dossier vous me croque une petite
graine qui a été voté au feu voyez mais
comment se sent loin du cynisme a ameuté
langage je me régale oui un sens des
chenilles confite dans l'accord
à
vous permettez plus un pc la porte en
face
mal à manger c'est fois les français
peuvent tellement de préjugés en matière
d'alimentation en même temps elle avoue
que ça n'a rien en ballots vous et les
chenilles validor elle cochon gaston
c'est mieux le cochon mais c'est juste
et le cochon gaston
un singe forme vous êtes vous par
l'humour
bonsoir edouard ça m'étonnerait partout
que c'est plus dans supplie là bientôt m
amuser mais ce temps les noeuds staline
de humboldt tout à fait plus comme tout
mais j'ai pas peur pour mon non pas du
tout je peux pas rester ici c'est plus
fort que moi et vous dire je vous en
supplie de louga connais vous je
m'envole sur la mine et je me suis un
très en sécurité auprès de monsieur
lazhar puis les 6 le caire 12h10 moi
j'aurais été prenez la voiture ne m'a
pas sauté gaston dans la campagne à
obala entendu mais pardonnez moi mais
j'étais jeune mathieu me suis né à paris
n'est ce pas et le lion les chenilles
edwards est vrai sont comprenez quand on
est habité au bas-rhin voiture
excusez-moi régime c'est cette tâche que
je fais là mais bon sens monsieur je
téléphonerai demain c'est ça
terme hommage gaston tu veux pas ramener
le petit il voulait profiter mon petit
monsieur me dit vous déposera l'opéra
voila voila l'excellente idée mais
comment ne peut-on pas un saint non non
ce gaz très fatigué il part demain soir
pour car ni la juste le temps de faire
ses bagages
voilà enfin mon cher gaston merci pour
tout et je te souhaite un bon séjour là
bas je décidais moizini volume je vous
quitte
malgré l'empressement aucun mais lucien
moins tenir à léopard lucien après coup
je ne bouge pas faire allez allez allez
o o madame by maroua
7 cette odeur d'encens ne vous gêne pas
au contraire parce que moi enfin c'est
une coutume que je pratique est en
colonie
oui et la paume on a le pouvoir
d'embaumer les rêves c'est joli et
francesca milieu de paris en ruisseau
c'est vrai je me sers pas trop madame
non non non pas du tout cette approche
ne va pas pour le moment
quand ce sera vous me direz oui ne vous
inquiétez pas alors voulez vous avez une
nature très ardent ça dépend des jours
voyez mais ce soir particulièrement vous
avez dû voir beaucoup de femmes martyres
du monde
oui moi je sais que le pire est à la
mode mais je suis quant à moi tout à
fait favorable à la métropole voyez vous
oui oui bon et bien eu parlez moi de
votre fameuse découverte en découverte
oui la terre marie-angèle vous avez dû
être très fiers de votre femme marie
thérèse marie ange marie angèle
au début je croyais veille on y apprend
après je l'écris de moins en moins et ce
soir je ne crois plus du nul c'était
c'était une indigène de carpentras
madame faut dire que j'avais un oncle
chez lequel j'allais passer mes vacances
là bas j'avais 17 ans elle 35 marié et
de surcroît la plus belle femme de la
ville ajoutez à cela que nous étions
voisins et le hasard il reste
malheureusement un d'un soir une veille
de pâques alors que nous croyons son
mari a bordeaux ils rappliquent à
l'improviste était la chose très mal à
cause du scandale j'ai dû j'ai dû
m'exiler madame mais vous me croirez si
vous voulez dix ans après ballotté par
les vents dans les mers du sud
j'ai décidé de donner à lui que je
venais de découvrir le nom de mon
premier amour
marie-claire marion marie angèle
et vous avez beaucoup de peine sur le
moment j'ai pleuré mais maintenant c'est
fini quand même oui oui vous avez aimé
beaucoup d'autres femmes au bain mon
dieu même j'avoue que j'ai goûté à de
nombreux blessés ya là bas oui toujours
là bas là va là bas avec à la barre elle
avait abordé au oui
alors là bonjour la pomme madame l'amour
tient une place prépondérante et où ce
que je reproche aux hommes d'ici c'est
qu'ils ont oublié l'essentiel c'est à
dire le plaisir plaisir d'amour
j'entends car ici qu'est ce que je vois
je vois un banquier qui vient tous les
samedis probablement à heures fixes se
payer de toutes ces largesses c'était
que rentrait juste moi encore un gamin
d'alleurs câline qui souvent des
prouesses qui seraient bien incapables
de réaliser
on est comme vous avez raison si vous
savez comment j'ai pu être naïve à quel
propos j'ai cru oui ce que j'ai pu
l'espérer a conduit ma gynéco je me
disais celui-là est différent des autres
mais au fond ils étaient tous pareils
aux souris tous jusqu'à ce soir par
madame alors en somme si je comprends
bien vous n'avez jamais connu le vrai
bonheur avoué jamais pauvre
vous permet début que je m'allonge sur
les dix ans je le sais vous en prie aime
la priorité que vous n'avez pas ses
premiers sous le choc alors maintenant
oui racontez moi comment cela se passe à
bornéo
moi ça se passe avant d'échouer alors je
sais pas si j'ai
ainsi alors voila voila quand on y va
grever un homme et qu'il brûle une
flamme ardente pour serrer ni son
premier geste consiste à lui faire don
d'un collier qu'il cache secrètement
sous l'oreiller de la belle à ces jeunes
oui c'est très gentil sympa si le
lendemain sérigny porte le collier la
partie est admis gagner mais les vagues
ne s'en tient pas la route mais alors le
lendemain autres donjons est de nouveau
là et il se plaint de violents maux de
tête
alors alors de ses mains virginale série
ni le caresse hauteur des tentes alors
lui une manifeste son plaisir par de
longs soupirs auquel elle répond
pareillement et après un long moment et
perdu de bonheur c'est ça il laisse
tomber sur ses épaules sa tête en eau
laurie et laurie sommeil le sommeil je
crois mais leur sommeil aux côtés de sa
bien-aimée jusqu'à ce que le soleil soit
haut dans le ciel
voilà alors à ce moment là probablement
il la prend dans ses bras il entraîne
rapidement d'un restaurant j'aurai le
miracle ça qu il a fallu soleil n'est
pas encore levé vous avez tout dit et et
la nuit très clair normalement c'est le
soleil nous deviner si la perte et de la
lune régime je vous jure que c'est le
solaire et non mais qu'est ce que vous
faites mais menez vous je vous adore et
je fais comme à bornéo
[Applaudissements]
que nous demandent tout d'un coup tu
déposes fait erreur je suis à la rue des
petites écuries à l'adresse habituelle
de monsieur masse bon et nous on m'a
renvoyé ou 12 boulevard solférino au
vésinet à côté de la maison de chantier
c'est bien ici
ces messieurs et dames et la maison de
santé ou monsieur battre en sait les
messieurs je suis le chef comptable de
la maison basse rend se lever seul mais
parce que bien alors vous annoncerez
monsieur lajoie s'est initié
[Musique]
la joie parfois à votre visite
bonjour monsieur battront essayez vous
employez laisse nous c'est vrai de vega
malouf a toujours très bien
alors la joie quelle nouvelle avant
toute chose si quelqu'un entre ici à
l'improviste
nous étions l'an dernier aux indes et je
suis à la veille de mon départ pour
bornéo 1 et tous les objets que vous
voyez là qui nous entourent ont été
l'année au cours de nos expéditions
commune car nous sommes vous et moi deux
grands voyageurs monsieur vallerand 710
en bis le noir nous l'avons ramené de
chez les mangeurs d'hommes dont vous
connaissez très bien
1 alors à autre chose on n'habite pas
châteauroux 1-1 on habite nulle part en
réalité nous globe trotter à travers le
monde soyez curieux seulement des
nouvelles terres que nous découvrons et
d'ailleurs nous avons à notre actif
lille marie josèphe
voilà ça va c'est bien clair dans votre
esprit tout ça mais il n'est pas très
monsieur vachon mesquine je sais pas
vous avez l'air troublé vous avez
baromètre tube les vues du baromètre
oui c'est un jeune lionceau
demi-pensionnaires l'épave où il était
dans sa niche bas de la grille j'ai
seulement vu une croupe que tu fais dit
qu'un refus
eh bien faites pas le faire c'est qu'il
dormait alors on va t'en mieux lors du
bon temps vous l'avez de tara pour vous
remettre le champ façon merci monsieur
mahjong cigale de bananier non non rien
monsieur le second a dit donc quand j'y
pense
une jeune et jolie jeune femme reste là
tu risque d'entrer ici à tout moment
alors s'il vous questionne vous étendez
pains vous répondez évasivement un voile
à compter sur moi écoutez vous savez
tout ce qui me concerne 1
alors quelles nouvelles de châteauroux
un arabe j'ai pris l'initiative de faire
un saut jusqu'à paris eut égard à de
petites complications qui sont nés en
votre absence
mais ça je l'aurais parié malgré votre
nom la joie c'est toujours un messager
de mauvaises nouvelles quelle
complication
monsieur renard demande a reporté au 15
prochain le piment des 120 milles
accepté pour fin de ce mois et je vais
me trouver à court pour mon échec avant
mais pourtant ils paient bien le renard
jusqu'à maintenant ruby surnom mais
heureusement depuis trente ans que je
suis dans la maison mais d'après mes
renseignements on parle d'une liaison
aux récentes qui est bi coûterait les
yeux de la tête
c'est une espèce de rousse au genre
fatal aux que l'on dit fantasque et
dépensier et j'ai peur qu'elle ne bêle
très loin notre client mais à bornéo
peut-être leader mais ce match mais je
te laisse à vous prévenir
alors que dois je faire bah je vois la
vie est courte chacun a droit à sa part
de folie vous reporterez l'échéance de
renard au 15 du mois prochain et je
ferai une avance personnelles que vous
comptabilisez compter sur vous et moi là
et si on vous demande des nouvelles à
châteauroux je vais très bien de vous
pouvez compter sur ma discrétion
monsieur bases morales arrageois est ce
qu'il ya de quel côté et par m ah non
vous n'avez rien crainte vous savez
passée elle aussi bleus y dort n'y a pas
de sortie derrière celle vue
un ami un ami la joie est plus qu'un ami
je tiens de mes plus fidèles compagnons
d'expédition en espagne toujours près de
moi à l'heure du danger les eaux dans ce
cas monsieur je vous dois beaucoup de
reconnaissance les amis lucien sont des
amis asseyez-vous il m'apportait
quelques trophées personnels parce que
mes quelques fois nous faisons des
échanges
je cherche les instruments madame avec
lesquels les chefs coupe les premiers
jets petites blessures le plateau d'un
coca yade
quel joli travail de six élus ou et le
cherchons des pièces de collection
madame également vous montrer la vie de
monsieur vincent 1 depuis dijon 21
communes d'être agréable de mettre son
dévouement au service d'un être
d'exception
c'est très agréable et émouvant souvenir
où devaient avoir tous les débats à la
ramasse mais c'est pas la joie
vous aimez pas aussi beaucoup beaucoup
hélas beaucoup de bornéo parce que vous
parlez d'un bond estimé qu il y revient
pour parer à la sienne vous n'avez pas à
lui arracher le moindre récit de ses
nombreux exploits
d'autant qu'un rêve autant qu'à la joie
ou m'a sauvé la vie pratiquement si vous
le permettez je vais prendre congé j'ai
un expert se gare d'orsay à 11h40 ouzou
par mon départ l'eau a toujours sa
toujours et la joie joie voyez comme le
bonheur peut transfigurer un homme mais
où j'avais vu aussi aussi troublé aussi
heureux si fantastique aujourd'hui
annonce à jamais a su matra un substrat
soyez francs la joie et j'ai aimé à
sumatra rapin ma connaissance c'est
jusqu'à ce jour à ce qu'une seule femme
a compté l'envol existence
marie-christine mise à part des enr
marie joseph marie josèphe larry envers
mario jean marie oger
dgo
je sais tout ça est un peu curieux mais
qu'est ce que vous voulez nous sommes
loin de 110 bars et ses calories
qu'est-ce que oui c'est de la part de
qui ah bonjour monsieur louis quand vous
avez une bête sur votre mur a tenté
c'est à l'atari je vois ce que voulait
c'était douaouda remettre à bosser
baromètre la mêlée c'est un jeune
lionceau âgés de huit mois plus tard
naît de bamako
oui bon ben jarry j'arrive tout de suite
mélanie nom viendra paramètres a cassé
sa chaîne il est sur le mur du voisin
2004 tout lanières
bon là je dois vous pouvez partir
maintenant si vous devez sortir je vous
attendrai monsieur ne seront pas bons
bah alors allons-y 600 samb y aller par
cette branche ont rejoint les j'ai tout
mon temps je me sens libre tu seras près
d'angers
je m'y engage un tracé la joie après
vous monsieur major français la joie
vous le preniez rien je suis là à péter
river on le devine d'entonner les noms
des mois par le passé crise
comment c'est toi c'est persie et dans
cette tenue
j'ai pris mes précautions
et soyez tranquilles cette fois ci on
m'attaque je pourrai répondre à et tu ne
te fait pas peur à billets comme ça il
faut que je vous prie alors un conseil
avant toute chose on ne vient pas
bousculer mon bonheur je suis en train
de vous oubliez tous et ce n'est pas le
moment de grave mais sert pas les
furieux quand il après vous aviez des
couches et il m'a dit avec son air
mauvais alors quoi vous n'êtes même pas
foutu de la garde et on vous fait
pourquoi tu me rappelait que font que
l'on vous donne et j'en passe vous savez
combien peut être grossi dans la colère
et la peur j'ai voulu éviter des ennuis
alors je vais promis de ramener ce
pourquoi je suis là ils essaient
d'arranger les choses exactement alors
on s'en va mais voulez tout de même pas
passer votre vie dans cette baraque
peut-être mais non plus vos directeurs
que vous a dépêché un médecin pour
constater votre disposition il me fera
un procès ça m'est égal
moi j'en ai soupé le serbe arrivé de toi
également aujourd'hui je l'espère un air
pur et j'entends vivre pour de bon avec
un homme un vrai celui-là façon vache
mais justement ça va encore donner grèce
mais eu la preuve qu'elle était mieux
aimé que je ne l'étais est tous sur
seulement de bien le connaître se basera
tous sortis glanant est connue
n'assistait pas pas le mien aussi au
moins avantageuses moral ça congé
définitif de vente d'or
oui voilà n y était pas comprise qu'est
ce que je vais te venu et bien tu es
jeune tu travailleras voici la dure
alors un peu de courage allez allez
matin ah les vacances
quoique ça ici je te renvoie à bruisser
mauricie 2 oui oui je sais quand tu
quittes enveloppe de co2 préjudice je
n'oublie pas que tu a dessiné une
affiche pour moi qui a servi à mon
lancement on ne sait pas défendre dans
la victoire
ouais bon alors comme je ne suis pas
méchante je vais été dédommagés et
comment
si tu veux je te fais cadeau de ma
voiture voilà c'est quentin non je te
donne de quoi te débrouiller pendant moi
je ferai le nécessaire auprès la gare
qu'est ce que je veux dire c'est pas mal
a les caisses qui ont quand même façon
on a une grande habitude
en fait pour l'assurance de la voiture
qu'on fait la police est réglé un an
d'avancé tu peux rouler non c'est à dire
que j'essaie de prendre sur moi oui tant
pis si chiale quand je serai seul je
regarde personne pas vrai au revoir et
bonne chance mon ami mais il passe par
derrière ça vaut mieux
oui on sadirac à bowie je serais déjà
dit oui oui oui bonjour à gavranches de
kent bonjour me voyez c'est pas perdu de
temps ce n'est pas tout si je suis à
wall oui ça je crois qu'ils n'ont pas
encore des nouvelles d'abord alors tu
vas bien jouer les ostrogoths al mais
c'est du passé
[Musique]
bon je crois que cette fois ci je tien
bo mer
si c'était vrai plutôt qu'on cherche
c'est gentil mk jamais de grillons de
combat et quand ils se sont bien battus
on leur fait définira une nationale
musicaux ted mais c'est un peu spécial
et ça ça ne me pose même pas de nom de
vivre le chien a pu et on an'a là on ne
touche pas ce sont des flèches
empoisonnées
alors voilà enfin je t'explique même
mois qui a vu notre rayon ya aussi à
lyon où et qui dans sa niche peut malgré
tout j'ai pu pour un safari de lempdes
effet que ça coupe le monsieur en
question et c'est aussi bien qu'il
parlera beaucoup mieux les magnifiques
que raconter autour des stands et
voluptueux à la fois sauvage et doux
lequel ben may large
je vis un rêve magnifique agathe cas là
il lui murmure à l'oreille ou étranges
qui ressemble à de la musique et puis tu
sais mon besoin d'affection
ah si je le sais je l'aimé bien il me
semblait que blotti dans ses bras j'ai
traité d'un même coup transformé
idéalisée il y en a aussi mais surtout
défendu associé à un destin enfin normal
est propre à rémois des grands voyages
mais ils ont bien sûr leur façon de
penser de s'exprimer
rodez mais il a entendu la femme d'un
bonhomme qui a vu le jour dans vos
girard qui n'a jamais quitté le 15e ça
peut vous faire que de l'amour
d'arrondissement plus de bonne volonté
que des capacités et un manque total de
fantaisie mon bon monsieur en question
est il aussi bien qu'il paraît y at il
une situation à 6 mais je veux pas pour
un peu demain pour mais tellement je
suis conquise
il des titres avant les immeubles en
pierres d'atlas a mis en garde je crois
mais je suis sûr d'une chose je laime
oui c'est très bien ça mais il faut
quand même assurer ses arrières
équipe 1 c'est là il en a l'air était-il
gay un enfant il chantait il m'a dit
régine c'est mon passé mon avenir
oui mais pour ce qui est du présent vous
at il fait un beau cadeau il m'a donné
le choix entre mille
qu'est ce que tu fais à ma place je les
prendrais tous sont comme disait
mademoiselle parent de journaux dont je
fus l'habilleuse euros bill walsh
inagaki nous disait elle ils font
beaucoup demandé à l'homme il faut
chaque jour me demander davantage
c'est au sacrifice qu'ils vous qu'on
sent que l'on mesure son avant centre à
lui pour ça le plus mais comme la
dernière des vols à 9
elle était très mature mais des hôtels
plus d'1h mieux offrants il faut dire
que même les bras d'un jeu était un
numéro non qu'est-ce que tu ferais à ma
place je lui demanderai de me sacrifier
ce qu'il aime le plus au monde quoi mais
ces chasses ses explorations ses
découvertes
s'il accepte c'est la preuve de son
amour mais s'il refuse si je le perds
mais pas de pétard si les parcelles
croyez-moi juge burgaud
agathe jeudi alors si l'on peut dire je
suis convoqué à 5 heures au commissariat
de police avec un lion liberté dans un
parc
entourée de hauts murs un jeune enfant a
reçu on verra bien il n'a jamais mordu
personne trois fois à ma connaissance
pendant le voyage mais c'était juste
pour s'habituer 10 mois à gaza dans des
villages et quelques robes et je me sens
si heureuse ici ce débat était même en
chérie tu es ici chez toi viendrait
alors il n'aura jamais de regrets aux
jeunes même si je m'installer ici avec
toi pour toujours au maire au contraire
c'est bien ainsi que j'envisage l'avenir
pareil au présent oui mais tu veux tu
suivi moi mais je suis prêt pour toi a
tout sacrifié ma vie mes amis ma
carrière le théâtre à n'importe quoi
mais moi aussi tu sais on ne connaît
vraiment l'amour de naître au sacrifice
qui bosse en écoute ce que tu viennes
c'est tellement vrai que c'est presque
devenu un proverbe
alors je voudrais pour être sûr de toi
que tu me donnes un gage mais lequel et
bien c'est très grave ce que je vais te
demander je voudrais que tu réfléchis
avant de répondre oui voila je voudrais
que pour moi tu renonces cette
expédition à toutes les voyages à ce qui
est à vis ton passé que nous demeurions
ici tous les deux avec agathe
tu puisses allemand de votre bonheur aux
accords d euros
non mais
mais réfléchissez à grenoble c'est tout
réfléchi c'est we say die aula la
sacoche tank sort que la vente il a
préféré qu'on peut très bien du sens à
son nom qui tue pas renoncé à tourner
dupuis 4 go seul coup tout ce que tu
aimes sont même tous ces sacrifices oil
quand je décide je ne pèse pas en jeu
libre c'est bien ça à la fin ça je
remplace le monde pas plus mais on ne
fera jamais le bonheur à l'un des plus
forts que jamais exigé de toi pareils
sacrifices
tu as pas deviner que c'était là une
simple épreuve il ya plus de figures aig
que je pouvais avoir
la bêtise de temps gêné dans ce coin de
banlieue mais c'est tout le contraire
d'un ferry qui se passe c'est à dire
c'est à dire tu ne comprends pas entre
viendront propres pâques que je veux
être pour toi une compagne jusque dans
l'aventuré il danger au besoin que je
tiens à partager ta vie ces risques que
je suis prête à partir demain demain à
te suivre où tu voudras à tdf russe qui
m'arrive
mais c'est fou mais c'est bien là la
[Musique]
capricieuse en savons pas si c'est aussi
beaucoup j'ai ben moi pas loin pendant
qu'elle ne peut répondre plus agaçante
tout est calme et vous calmez vous ça va
s'arranger pays et vous allez on n'est
pas encore parti mènera galicien bien
sûr j'aimerais tant mini dp aussi
fatiguée bien de moi à boire son biberon
très unis aussi et si beau sapin naturel
moins quelques mois je pense bien alors
qu'en partant nouveau bornéo
enfin je sais pas je passerai chez
cookson dépendant du bateau vous nous
amenez un bâton
oui je peux vous emmène en bateau
et tout part camp nou de marseille ou
bordeaux ça dépendra des escales ce sera
nouveau pour tout le monde
je veux dire pour vous mais le temps d
ici c'est vraiment féerique la barre 0
de raconter mon cas n'est grave ont fait
pas du tout du tout du tout on vit dans
des cases dont ils vont envoyer argile
13,8 et puis il n'y a rien dans les
casses ont dors par terre sur des nattes
graisseuse dans un coin ya quelques
accessoires ou sans enfant vous
messieurs
ils écrivent à l'épouvantable
épouvantable le climat très chaud et
très humide 40 degrés à l'ombre l'été
1 si bien que chaque jour dans un
dizaine de là bas tu obligé de nous
éventaires que ponk à un noir en plus
[Musique]
si la nuit la nuit très froid - 2 - très
dangereuse aussi on est obligé de
laisser les lampes allumées dans les
cases où quand il ya des serpents qui
entrerait épais et puis des puits et des
potes les serpents et est scorpion nous
a dit j'ai entre diffuse les typhons
mais qui tend la main
alors là je ne veux pas vous en parler
ah oui pour se nourrir c'est immangeable
avaient tous la barre est à base de deux
chenilles grillé et de riz macérer dans
l'huile de ricin lost épouvantable
essence l essor tout ça sans cesse à
cause du froid enfin vous faites comme
vous voudrez mais je tenais à vous
signaler quand même je n'ai pas pas vous
y allez vous allez être amené oui
pourquoi pas nous
écoutez si vous y tenez à votre santé à
dreux les eaux
oui à bornéo oui oui c'est bien gentil
tout ça mais où est ce que ça se trouve
bon niveau
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
au gal température à tacoma aux non moi
dieu merci je me tais toi comme moi
j'adore la chaleur n'a pas peur des
fièvres lambert mais non tu es heureuse
qu'on chérit depuis un mois nous sommes
ensemble n'est pas connu une seconde
d'ennui
au début j'ai très peur ah ben moi donc
de quoi dont je me disais je ne suis
rien moi et me tout le monde quelqu'un
mon jeu ce n'est le privilège de
personne ne va comprendre
moi je suis sans calcul tu sais je
t'aime non pas parce que tu es quelqu'un
mais parce que tu es toi et le jour nous
sommes connus si tu m'avais tu pars
donner des bonbons à l'emploi tout
autant du mon manteau vestiaires belge
ferait remarquer la même façon je te
jure
ce que vous voulez pour des jeunes
également pilote le tout à new si c'est
possible et pour monsieur brian rooney
sol et on va manger là je sais que ça
vous fait plaisir non plaisante voie
sera un steak aux pommes et comme pas
senti non parce qu'il ya de l'autre
celle ci avait 46 3
bientôt ça va ouvrir samedi à la fin
mais est ce bien que les îles
polynésiennes et bradée sud sur l'impact
qu'ils font a dit à la barre et ifo va
qu'est ce que c'est au juste
je vous montrerai en passant mais ça se
remarque mais ça se voit bien qu'ils
font en général
bon pour le moment celle commandée le
déjeuner et vous me rapportez de mes
cigarettes
qu'est-ce que je ne visais pas tenir
oh
par exemple gastaud issement c'est une
surprise tout sorti vous et entremont
vieux alors enfin à cannes ça s'est bien
passé
oui nommé où je suis ici à bornéo
voilà alors si je comprends bien vous
n'avez pas quitté le vésinet non mais
nous allons bientôt papa pour les îles
nous attendons la fin de la saison des
plus précis je vous présente l'un à
l'autre discrètement je m'éloigne au
moment où vous avez leur souhaiter de
tête à tête je pars pour cannes j'en
reviens je vous retrouve dans une case
déguiser un sénégalais ep on s'entraîne
4' vous ne mettez pas vos parties nature
vont aider à nous dans les oreilles
maintenant la du pays
qu'est ce que vous en faites mais quel
pays bas bornéo paris héberge chez
régine je vous fais mes compliments vous
demandez le chien dans un bel état
rappeur et nous vous le rend pas je le
garde
il est brillant ce point on veut il est
sincère il ne ment pas
c'est vrai et l'ase enfin je tâche de
rester naturel
c'est un homme simple n'est-ce pas le
sien bah mon dieu oui nous inspirer à
mener une liste artifices mois d'un
compagnon loyal fort aujourd'hui c'est
chose faite
bon vieux j'espère qu'on ne gâtent de
voile adieu aux deux chevrons rien
presque alors depuis un mois que je suis
parti tu vas passer ton temps à
construire des décors qg des j'adore ça
mais tu es quelqu'un d'un genre de
vottem qui exactement et qui épouse m
king c'était un gars c't'un
explique-t-il eh bien là potemkine était
un ministre russe qui pour complaire à
sa souveraine de la grande catherine il
falloir que la russie était très riche
et très peuplée
construisez des villages sur son passage
village qu'on démolisse et tout de suite
après c'était délicat mais plutôt à ceux
qui je l'aï terminée mais il n'est pas
le seul n'est pas un qui est à son sujet
le nouveau nobel mois du monde camille
compris son jeu merci ça nous a menés là
bas parce qu'ils nous croient incapable
de supporter les classiques de
l'expédition
c'est bien il ya un peu de ça des ta
carrière des travaux qui sacrifie tout
ça pour un caprice d'un caprice mais
dites-moi gaston vous allez un peu fort
je sais ce que vous pensez vous dit
elle va l'accaparer et bien non gaston
je serais pour lucien la vraie compagne
contraire les lois de le retenir en
france six mois qu'il entraînerait et
nous irons loin du siea très loin même
on est calme toi au moins tu ferais
modifié ses projets au contraire il faut
vous apercevez enfin quelle femme je
suis
alors mon pauvre vieux tu enlèves
celui-là et imprimerie à savent plus
d'un mois que tu porteras châteaux
bastides imagine que ça fait trente ils
ont menacé la ruine
c'est le chemin et tu ne fais rien pour
l'éviter à quoi bon je suis sur ma
lancée
elle est si douce que je me laisse
glisse ça t'a coûté combien de toi moi
cette petite histoire de karnataka peu
près ce que j'avais envie d'ailleurs et
en plus j'ai pris d'autres dispositions
lesquels j'ai vendu mon imprimerie n'ont
ils pas vrai mais je t'assure bon jérôme
a trouvé un acquéreur
j'attends ici aujourd'hui même pour
signer les papiers mais tu vas tout
engloutir et cette aventure sans issue
tu aimes donc à ce point et je le prouve
et gauthier oui c'est un frère qui pas
oui un frère qui a connu ton père ou ton
grand père ma soeur suzanne aussi tu
n'as pas le droit d'agir ainsi
l'amour est une chose à vianne et une
eau abcd ça fait deux bons soit jeune
homme que diable et j'en suis un c'est
même là toute l'histoire songe que d'ici
deux mois tu auras plus un sou arriver
quel souvenir
oui mais ça se voit pas et souvenirs
malheureux rassure-toi beau comme ils
sont je ne laisserai personne etc obligé
le conseil de fous l'camp pleure un bon
coup si tu lèves mais pour l'amour de
dieu tout le temps ouais c'est bien la
question tout ce que tu deviens est vrai
à wayaux en m'accrochant à régine je
risque de faire une blague non membres
s'assureront et si j'arrive à
l'acquitter je pouvais peut-être
rétablir mais ça faisait pas voilà tu as
compris mais à la réflexion gaston c'est
toi qui as raison je te le fais pas dire
seulement voilà je n'ai aucune envie de
la quitter champ et non
le bonjour monsieur et madame bonjour
monsieur lajoie
bonjour monsieur le notaire nous attend
avec les actes à côté au café du
rond-point très bien que la choix on
vous demande deux minutes le temps de
changer et je suis à vous vous allez
mieux monsieur m'a 3 je vais très bien
qu'est ce qu'il à toujours vouloir que
je sois malade tu es là alors alors
comment le trouvez-vous très mal
vous croyez la joie le chef comptable de
la maison ma gens voudraient bien table
et mon pauvre monsieur ne m'en parlez
pas me suis effondré qu'il pensait cela
d'un homme aussi pondéré et que monsieur
gbagbo et qui administre la caisse
d'epargne de sa ville
c'est rassurant pour les épandre on va
sur l'état d'esprit nous paraissait
d'aplomb jusqu'à ces derniers temps mais
malheureusement il ne l'est plus songez
que nous sommes ici à bornéo
nous sommes d'abord des hauts pics
demain à saint ybars ou à java mais
alors tout le monde voyage ici vous
l'avez remarqué le silence pas si vous
me permettez question monsieur la maison
santé est si si courbis ici c'est une
annexe je suis à bien alors partons la
joie va pour borner au café du coin
puisque d'interdît à temps passant aux
actes ea
si on pose des questions la joie il ya
un an nous étions aux indes aux seins au
tibet exactement mais pourquoi ils
ferment chasse qui le tigre à toi je
suis fatigué mais bien sûr vous avez
vous la tête rabah très sincèrement je
me le demande
alesi est passé pour après coup monsieur
mazerand à agos de baromètre j'en étais
sûr je me demande si vous aimez les
animaux
regarde où son parti ces messieurs je ne
suis pas à même de sortir ma décision
est prise à gaz si nous laissons ici les
amis les chiens aboyaient nous l'enlever
alors c'est tout ce que j'ai fait j'ai
téléphoné à cooke et j'ai retenu trois
passages pour bornéo et abandonner des
mois laissez rien encore je lui fais la
surprise dans deux ou trois jours le
temps que vous qu'elle est mal qu'est ce
que nous risquons alors à quand l
aventure la vie tout au plus les faits
s'ils acceptent que j'aurais du mal à
croire qu est un amoureux de sa carrière
quoi ça l'idée moi tu passeras rue
marbeuf retirer mais mal et agathe en
route pour borner au casque acer c'est
bien monsieur masson qui va sortir
ensuite on a su tarim agathe
rassurez-vous vous à l'épaule entend s'y
attendre aussi longtemps qu'il me faudra
pouvait disposer la 4c plus surprenant
alors où est il où est elle vous direz à
votre maîtresse que nous sommes
impatients la voir aller
c'est qu'ils m'en reste enfin cigare
balle monsieur serval si vous permettez
je voulais déjà dit le fait que nous
soyons allié dans cette affaire
n'implique pas nécessairement de votre
part un taux de familiarité que ne
justifie ni votre âge et votre situation
dia monsieur serval vous avez le rapport
de l'agent sont un joli et ne se sert
d'aller aussi et photographies bien vous
produirez le tout au bon moment sans
éclat je crois que nous avons en main de
tels atouts il sera difficile à notre
bonhomme de sentir et quentin résine
elle va faire une de ces gueules
rachetant ge pour l'amour de dieu
surveillez votre langage pendant dieu
bonjour eva vous avez vous reste en jeu
de vente une femme celle usage
quoi qu'on ait à lui dire non à ces vous
messieurs et dites moi le plus
rapidement possible l'objet de votre
visite au moins vous en doutez pas
régine bon de vous je m'attends à tout
la présence d'un serval surprend
davantage
alors monsieur le voyageur n'est pas là
c'est lui moi c'est moi vous voulez voir
les deux et pour la soirée finale
il est à la chasse qu'entendez vous par
il est à la chasse nous aimerions savoir
quel est son sport préféré s le tigre à
dos d'éléphant ou bien le lion à
d'autres chameau êtes marrants nous vous
écoutons régine non je comprends votre
des plis je vous ai planté là un peu
brutalement est bon je tiens à mon
excusé mais je
m'occuper d'un certain toupie en
essayant de démolir un homme dans le
prestige vous gêne il n'est pas de votre
trempe lui heureusement il faudra
trouver autre chose messieurs lisez les
documents restants la masse rang lucien
emile bernard mais à châteauroux 1 en
1866 libre f1 primeur 4 place gambetta
successeur de son père maison fondée en
1860 deux juges suppléants au tribunal
de commerce
administrateur adjoint de la caisse
d'epargne est conseiller municipal
depuis 1902
c'est tout n'a jamais quitté sa ville
natale que pour aller faire son service
militaire à aubusson
où il a été réformé pour pieds plats
jouit de la sympathie de ses concitoyens
après je viens de vous lire la note qui
m'a été communiquée par une agence
privée à mais j'ai fait mieux ah oui tu
allé moi-même à châteauroux et j'ai
mangé de lapin au restaurant du commerce
dont le propriétaire n'est autre qu'un
beau frère à lui spécialisé dans les
moules au gratin la manoeuvre est un peu
grosse messieurs il faudra trouver autre
chose
j'ai moi d'autres témoignages mouvement
malheureusement les faits sont là et si
nous avons tenu à vous apporter des
détails c'est pour vous mettre en garde
contre les dangers à venir
on ne sait jamais d'un fou s'il n'est
pas dangereux une aventure comme celle
là régine est indigne de vous enfin
s'ils voulaient bien d'ouvrir les yeux
et rentrer à paris on sent prêt à passer
l'épongé et ce vice apal est chargé
d'aucune mission monsieur je verrai ce
que j'ai un faible pour régine vous
ramène dans ma bagnole je serai avenue
bugeaud ce soir à partir de 6h j'espère
que d'ici là vous aurez réfléchi
que de monde monsieur puisse connaître
l'objet de cette expédition
cette expédition est une simple visite
nous ne parlons pas comme vous le
langage de la junte parfait serveuse et
nous ne sommes que de vulgaires pékin
nous chassons le lapin coûte quoi
s'agit-il je vais vous dire la position
que vous le promets tier de rester
calmes mais je m'efforcerai messieurs
pour que d'essayer ma confiance en vous
je vous demande de ne répondre par oui
ou par non c'est très important je vous
répondrai avec ma franchise habituelle
connaissez-vous châteauroux dans l'indre
si je collais châteauneuf bien sûr chat
ou même question mais où est le mal
avez vous connaissance d'une maison
mazerand 4 place victor hugo à danon
place victor hugo pas du tout
place gambetta a alors permettez s
gambetta victor hugo mais ça fait
beaucoup
cette maison a été fondée en 1864 62 et
vous parents d'emma souvent de là bas si
je suis parent dit oui êtes-vous adjoint
municipal à la caisse d'epargne non non
ce sont deux fonctions très différente
d'abord et par ailleurs outre que je
trouve cet interrogatoire extrêmement
déplacé et que j'ai de compte à rendre à
personne
la vérité ne me fait pas peur mais
quelle était la vérité je ne vous la
dirai m pas devant des étrangers qui
n'ont rien à faire ici
mais les chiens dans cette attaque je
vous demande de répondre et de confondre
ces messieurs vous n'êtes pas libre à
châteauroux n'est ce pas en quoi cela
gêne m
mais vous êtes menés là bas vous savez
il faut bien être quelque part mais avez
vous voyagez souvent oui oui on aurait
dit vous allez à bornéo
il avait beau chassé en avez vous
ramener ses trophées avez vous découvert
la terre marie-antoinette répondait
mariage
non j'ai besoin de votre réponse
immédiate et publique us du sien je suis
mort y est vous mentir je serai franc
origine je vous ai menti
vous voyez enfin nous y sommes
vous avez inventé toutes ces histoires à
100 que ces objets et allez-vous
prouesse disons que j'ai un peu exagéré
pour parler vous tessin je vais le
savoir vous le saurez mais pas devant
ces messieurs à voir la chine qui vous a
eu le monde portait ou d'abord un petit
la parole et magasins mais moi je la
prends je vous la daurade monsieur en
raison de votre âge avancé tu sais pas
quels sentiments bénigne chez lui en
touche étrangle ont pas mais vous avez
monté son origine ne veut pas que le
petit interviennent je le répète c'est
bien foutu d'origine mais en exagérant
rien monsieur si j'ai un peu déformé la
vérité c'est pour obéir un sentiment
sincère dont je n'ai pas à rougir
et moi je peux garder la tête haute
autant vous en tous les cas merci
origines depuis de quel droit joué vous
les juges
donc toi vous mêlez vous y répondez
monsieur vous servez le m'avait lancé
mais quoi j'ai fait payer êtes riches
les bijoux les toilettes cela de guerre
et cela flatter votre orgueil de vous
dire mon amant mais vous vous moquez
bien de la femme et n'ont ils pas toi
cas la boîte et j'espère que ça suffit
comment il a la voiture
qu'est ce que c'est que cette histoire
de voiture 1 à 2 degrés c'est une simple
opération d'exécution voulant me
reprendre vous le pensez car une fois de
plus jamais un mois tandis que monsieur
masson homélie à matisse est entendu et
j'ai commis la sottise de le croire
c'était charmant meules phr soyez pro
qui lui bas du mois tout sacrifier son
argent ses amis ses espoirs
ah oui tout j'ai vendu ma maison de
commerce messieurs je n'ai pas arrêté
pour un mois de bonheur et je les
connais l'héritage de ma mère par amour
pour origine mais je vais tout ça sans
aucun regret autre que celui de ne
pouvoir faire davantage pour elle alors
aligné dans autant si vous pouvez oui
mais vous avez arraché mademoiselle
losange à sa profession à son public à
ses amis voilà 6 à 12 ans à l'école tané
real avait du temps je vous écris c'est
ce que je voulais être seul
allez je vous donne 24 heures pour
choisir entre la ville je vous ai fait
et ce tartare à la banque venir à star
ma terre jetée menti parce que je t'aime
et tu ne peux pas m'ont dit beaucoup tu
sais bien que tu aurais pas foutu de moi
[Musique]
moi je suis très non pas moi jamais
m'enfin régine nous sommes tout de même
pas des ennemis j'espère mais non dis
moi ce que je peux te poser une dernière
question le jour où nous nous sommes
connus si je t'avais dit valable je suis
très malheureux parce que je vous aime
mais le petit provincial que je suis ne
trouve pas les mots pour vous le dire
même en plus cher désir de vous aimer
profondément et ma plus grande crainte
ne pas être digne de vous est ce que tu
pourrais seulement écouter peut-être
alors que j'ai bien fait de mentir car
grâce à mon mensonge pendant ces trois
mois
j'ai vécu un bonheur inoubliable
origines dont je ne marchande pas le
prix quand même celui de la peine qu'il
me laisse et si je dis cela ce soit au
moment de partir c'est parce que
maintenant là je ne joue plus et que si
je suis ridicule ou malades ils
eh bien je te permets d'en rire et même
de temps moquer car grâce au ciel je
t'aime profondément et le reste n'a
aucune espèce d'importance
pardonne mais c'est moi qui te demande
pardon régime et si nous parlions
bourgogne et où on pouvait pas commencer
par la côte d'azur pour commencer ce que
tu sais moi vous dire et les voyages
j'aime bien les faire mais sans trop
bouger si je comprends bien tu es un
voyageur immobile voilà bien pour une
fois c'est l'exacte vérité mes premiers
mois du moins qu'un jour nous partirons
tous les deux bourgogne au bond et que
je te le promets depuis le temps qu'on
en parle
et puis je veux dire une chose moi aussi
je voudrais bien savoir où ça se trouve
bornéo
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
la pièce que nous avons joué pour vous
ce soir et de roger ferdinand
les décors de roger hart
[Musique]
les costumes de donald r noël
avec les guillaumont correa
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
olivier lejeune
robert partie
[Musique]
laurence badie
[Applaudissements]
bernard-charles ans
[Musique]
jean pierre delage
les claire maurier
et de michel roux
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]